today yeah i'm i'm always youtube hi minnie hello hey i'm
live you guys are live yeah we are we're live we're live now
yeah we're alive hot mic hot mic don't worry we're just
looking at each other's bodies leaks leaks that's all oh i'm
i'm frightened i'm intrigued and frightened yeah this is all
meaning yeah you played power world before yes okay a long
time ago though all right it's basically the same they
basically is the same until you like get to like level 30 or
something i think but like there are i know you get bigger
you get bad there's like new new areas so they added a lot
of new areas and new world like places to explore but
everything's like very similar up to like level i think like
level 20 to 30 um uh but like there are new pals around but
obviously the the newer stuff is like deeper into the game
so if you played it before like it's literally the same
tutorial same beginning section and everything okay do you
hear me running no but i think i just caught a glimpse of
what you look like but that could be okay i was thinking
about like do you go for cute or do you go for freak I think
we I don't know Nimi follow your heart follow what your
heart desires I already made mine and I started dying to the
cold I think it's safe to just capture the game right like
yeah yeah yeah because like the password is like oh look at
us why are we gray Nimi and I are both gray am I gray on
your screen?
no you're not there's gray no we're really hold on there's
something wrong with Amu oh Yeah, Limu, you look normal.
Yeah, you look normal.
Oh, I think it was a setting that I turned on.
Everyone except Gogi is gray.
Hold on.
I gotta show you.
Why me?
Why am I gray?
I don't know.
You're like a healthy pink, but look at us all.
Wait, why are you gray?
Why am I gray?
I don't know, man.
Hold on.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna capture the game to try and fix it.
Oh, my God, your thighs, girl.
Your thighs.
Yeah, but look at her arms, though.
dead leg day you guys are so beautiful we need to hit the
gym and you know you're out here looking like we were just
so normal i gotta get i gotta catch up to doki though i
gotta yeah yeah do my legs all right let me you can't keep
hold on there's a reason why no wonder i no wonder i'm
lacking you can't there's no way you catch up to me graphics
oh i think it was actually i turned a particle setting down
or something and it and i think it screwed things well let
me see oh and then when we start spreading out we can use
voice proximity so to do voice proximity make sure you go to
options um option sounds and it's like a little
counterintuitive but it says on but you gotta put that off
so mute my voice and mute my voice is muted biteable yeah
yeah i see i turned it on yeah and then you push the talk is
deep but you can rebind it so Yeah, I'm gonna do that.
Yeah, hello.
You guys hear me?
Oh, I hear you in the game.
Yeah, because, like, we're gonna be...
We might have to split up soon, unless...
Because...
If we wanna start paling.
Oh, yeah, I can hear you.
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
I can hear you.
I think I'm hearing you in Discord, though.
No, I hear you...
No, I hear Limeo on Discord and in the game.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I hear Doki and Bose.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
am i in the game oh yours is so muted it says it's so muted
yeah i see like there's like a little icon above your yeah
it's above your it says it should be on it should be off
mute my voice mute my voice off yeah yeah you know if you
and doki like combined uh forces oh that was what he said
yeah if you both combined forces you would be the best
bodybuilder ever you're so huge i'm getting on your
shoulders i'm getting on your shoulders in the game yeah you
are in the game you are i mean you are a bit quiet yeah i'm
you know i'm discord i mean you're a bit quiet in game
though um oh that's better it's better now okay okay uh let
me sorry let me mute this squirt all right actually the
voice is pretty good you sound like the same thing you did
like I'm here.
I actually have to go and double check.
I actually need a Discord.
I want to do voice practicing in case we all split up and
then we all start screaming and other sides of the world.
Wait, I can't hear anyone anymore.
Wait.
Can you hear me?
Hello.
Hi.
Hey.
Oh, I don't think, let me go unmute on Discord.
Oh, I forgot to turn off the mute nearby voice.
Oh, okay.
Oh, hi.
Hi.
I thought I thought I was like I wasn't going crazy I knew I
couldn't hear everyone else wait it's gone again hold on no
no nobody responded we'll just like go to walk you for a
second you're not going crazy you're not going we just we're
all fixing a setting I just didn't respond
you weren't going crazy I was like Oh, okay, wow, now...
Nobody wants to talk to you right now.
Yeah, exactly.
You guys, I think I'm muted.
I think I'm muted.
And everyone's like, she thinks she's muted.
Yeah, she thinks, yeah, look at her.
No one, people just didn't want to talk to you.
That's because I'm too beefy.
I'm gonna roll off this cliff.
No, do a clip.
No, do it.
You got so much to Pal for.
All right, we gotta press this.
We gotta press this to start your tutorial.
travel event oh so you can so your fast travel everywhere
old granddaddy has joined i i hope that i hope that snuffy i
that's my grandpa i invited grandpa yeah family bonded
exercise happy oh there's old granddaddy he's coming in say
hello over there yeah i like how they changed it so that
like Here, because it was like a whole different section on
a beach, right?
Because I remember punching a cat off of it.
No, it's always there.
You're not there anymore.
It always started here.
Really?
Yeah, I thought it always did.
No, no, no.
I feel like on release, it's the section over here, like in
this real bit here.
Yeah, on release.
I put it around here.
Oh, on release.
It was here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's where it was.
Yeah, no, you were right.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I was like, wait a second.
Right here.
Like, because you just go out of the cave and then you're...
I don't remember any of this.
Is there a little statue down there?
What's this statue?
It's lore.
It's like the new thing they added, where they added lore to
the game.
Yeah, I don't need lore to punch.
Yeah, I don't need lore.
We're here to catch pals.
Alright, is this...
That has to be snuffy.
That...
Yes!
Granddad!
Let's go welcome old granddaddy!
Grandpa!
Oh, granddaddy!
dad you're so thin i like it i just don't be can't even hear
us yet she's she's just like where is why is nobody talking
really it's it's grandma his super standard daughters and
then like two bodybuilders as in it will turn if you press
off there you go let's hope that old grandpa knows how to
use the computer i really like old grandpa's bra you know
the older they get the sagger true true that's not a bra
he's holding his buns in there yeah you know how like old
people like to take fruit around for a snack he's got two
oranges in there or something oh that's true oh yeah yeah
yeah that's what i mean He needs them.
He's just skin and bone.
Yeah.
It's important not to get scurvy.
That's so true.
Wait, someone has to take care of grandpa.
Not me.
No, no, no, no, tagging out.
Tagging out.
I don't have to take care of grandpa.
So let's take care of grandpa.
We have to put him in the home.
I got grandpa.
Come on, my arms.
Boogie, why do you look so sunburned?
Oh, we're literally outside.
What do you mean?
We're touching grass.
are you punching grandpa let's be squat next to grandpa you
guys are so lucky i turned pvp off i wanted to turn it on
but tara is a coward i know i technically i have control the
server i could turn it on i wait until like the end of the
session don't tell matara turn it on and then punch her to
death but then no the server restarts though we have to
restart the server if i turn Wait, but Matara's down here.
We can turn it on.
We turn it on.
We don't tell her.
We run up here with our crossbows that we've just gotten and
beat the snot out of her.
Yes.
All right.
Are we all down?
Like, that's what you get for being late.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, I'll turn it on.
Let me get on.
We just all have to sign in again.
Let me uncapture the game just in case it shows the fucking
IP as we disconnect.
Don't worry, it does it.
You're fine.
You're so fine.
All right, let me turn it on.
Let me find the settings real quick.
Where the fuck is PvP?
Shut up, Chickpea.
I'm going to punch you.
Chickpea.
You punch the Chickpea.
Get him in.
Yeah.
Look at my arm.
You should get better punch power.
You should get better punch power if you have, like, good
arm.
All right, you guys ready?
I'm restarting service.
Okay, bye!
Bye!
Alright,
server is being turned on now.
You guys can't enter it because it needs a password.
There we go.
I should save it.
Alright, it's time to test it out.
Test out the PvP.
Imagine if it is boobs.
Alright, I'm first in.
Oh.
Alright, we gotta test it out.
Where is she?
Hello?
Hey.
Wait, how long?
Has a murder occurred already?
Yeah, I don't know who killed her.
What happened, man?
Man, what happened?
Well, at least we know PvP works, guys.
Someone killed him in.
Oh, wait.
I can only hear you, Nimmy.
I can hear you, too.
Can you guys hear me?
Just, I don't know.
Wait, Doki, can you hear us?
Yeah, I can hear you guys.
Wait.
Don't forget to change your microphone from the Elgato HD
capture 60.
Oh, I was on push to talk for some reason.
Yeah, I can hear you guys.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know why it gave me push to talk.
I can't hear Limo either.
We need better.
Oh, Limo, you might be on push to talk.
talk but but uh pvp is on so you watch this i died oh my god
dang it was that was aggressive oh shit oh shit oh shit i'm
gonna send it to me if you hit me you hit grandpa you hit me
i don't care i'll hit grandpa oh no i hit grandpa i'm done
she's gonna beat up grandpa
to talk the whole time yeah like when it reset it stopped
actually like obeying the push to talk oh god we're going
crazy go to the catfire go to the catfire the catfire there
you go we'll be warm here okay i'm coming back you're gonna
you're gonna get punched so hard man
wait you're taking wait they're they're taking cold damage
okay we sat here for so long that night hit we gotta get
grandpa grandpa's gonna die of cold I'll save him I'll save
man grandpa was your responsibility punch him over here
punch him over here before we punch him over I don't know
just my stream say Can I punch him?
No, I can't.
Grandpa, I hate to do this to you.
All right, I turned up the master slider up sound.
Yeah, let me know if it's better.
She knew they would never advance.
We'll work together.
We will work together, guys, I believe.
We'll work together, definitely.
Yeah.
I don't know how it's going to work with friendly fire.
I'm absolutely going to accidentally shoot someone.
No, there's no way.
reply to the pals because that's gonna be fucked okay yes
okay oh jesus i believe in that even a thing i i was because
i turned both options on i oh guys i'm worried grandpa
hasn't respawned oh my grandpa's dead grandpa i hate when my
grandpa doesn't respawn
I'll go check on him.
Wait, your grandpa doesn't respond?
Oh, he's going.
He's here.
I have a very important question, Toki.
Does friendly fire apply to pal spheres?
No.
Okay.
Wait, okay.
So you won't get caught.
Not that I would ever do that to anybody.
Yeah, not that.
Can you put a person in a pal?
Wait, you can put people.
Wait, how do I stop running?
Shift.
I pressed a button!
Oh, it gets kind of funny.
Like, press the run button again.
Yeah, press...
Oh, okay, there you go.
It gets kind of weird and it's like sticks and puts if
you're like, you're looking at a menu or tapping or
something.
My grandpa's gonna die again!
No!
One!
We could technically all...
Oh, grandpa!
Come here.
Everyone!
Come here!
물, come here!
Grandpa!
Come here!
Yeah!
Yay!
Oh!
Labu got so excited.
I saw that.
I didn't do anything.
I didn't do a god damn thing.
We can't hear you, Grandpa.
Grandpa, you might need to open mic.
Grandpa.
Pow, Straßen.
Do open.
Oh!
I can hear you.
Hey.
Wait,τι here, grandpa's here.
Hey grandpa!
Honestly, this is like accurate role-playing of grandpa who
just like one hit from dead at all times.
Oh shit!
Get him dead!
Oh damn!
You get an emote wheel?
Where's the emote wheel?
Press four, press four.
Hmm.
I like how the first option for dance was like fucking spin
around on your hands.
That's how I dance.
Oh!
Shit!
You take damage from the...
You take damage from the evo!
Wait, what do you guys evo?
Press 4.
You press 4.
Oh, 4?
Alright.
Alright, Matara's coming in.
Okay.
Yeah.
Let's see.
We agree that we, like, punch the shit out of her, right?
Yeah!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, we gotta do it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
When she spawns it.
We'll know when she spawns it because we'll see it.
Wait, should we all be dancing and then we go around?
Yeah, she's like, wait, wait, because like, we should go up
to where she spawned.
Yeah, we need fire.
Hold on, we need fire so we don't freeze to death up there.
One sec.
We'll just wait till it's daytime, honestly.
By the time she gets in here, it'll be daytime.
I can also make fire.
Oh, that's true.
You go progress.
I have learned how to make fire.
Oh, my God.
Behold.
How do you feel?
Why are you leveled, too?
Have you been farming?
Grandpa?
Yeah, grandpa.
How are you leveled?
Oh, it's because...
It's because Lymo beat up a chicken earlier.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, you literally killed me.
Yeah, oh, all right.
Oh, look at that.
Lymo's, see, Lymo will be the...
Wait, we don't need fire.
It's morning.
All right.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, no, not yet, not yet, not yet, not yet, not yet.
It's gone, it's gone, it's gone.
Okay, now we can go.
All right.
She'll be, like, right here, and we can all dance around
her.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Am I safe from freezing to death?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If I'm holding fire and I start breathing, I'll see what
happens.
Yeah, you're gonna slap her with the torch?
Maybe.
Beautiful.
And now we wait.
Now we wait.
She should...
This is really nice.
Yeah.
It's kind of like sensory.
and sing yeah it's like a for like a flash mob we come on
matara we're waiting you know like i don't know about you
guys but obs mute's like discord join song so she could have
joined and been listening this whole time and i wouldn't
have noticed no we can't because we're all deafened though
oh true i don't have obs open so i i didn't hear anything
fair enough you're not you're not gonna give us This is a
ritual.
She'll be here.
But she might have been watching one of our streams.
Okay, but checking my chat count, my chat list right now.
It's okay.
It's all right.
Don't worry, she'll be here any second now.
What if she's like already past this area?
Because she said she was going to check out the server.
What if she spawns like 80 miles?
She's like tri-largely or something.
She has like a base already.
gets worried she'll be like where are the girls where are
they also yeah she's waiting down there for us yeah i don't
see a name tag yeah we get out by the way guys we're slowly
starving while doing this we got yes i'm like 50 something
percent yeah i'm committed i'm committed too well well okay
oh whoa she's here oh she's here so you hate me huh They're
all muted.
I hear Batara right now.
I'm screaming.
Sounds, controls.
I'm gonna scream at them.
Do you hear?
Who has like, who has like Discord like a year.
Yeah, you hear her.
I can't hear her.
Oh, she's like, I'm gonna scream at them when I get in.
I'm gonna prank them so hard.
Meanwhile.
What do we die?
I feel like there's like a non-zero chance we accidentally
hit each other here rather than her.
Yeah.
And we all die.
We die together.
It would be pretty fun.
Luigi wins by doing nothing.
We all just die.
Well, we are giving her something to scream at.
True.
Yeah.
The shading on our like the insides of our legs is really
red.
Where is she spawning?
Where is she spawning though?
Where is she gonna come?
We might have made a character.
Where is she gonna...
If she shows up by the Skeleting Party survivor, do we just
sprint over there?
Yeah, we just sprint over there.
No, we say nothing and let her come close to us.
It's even there.
This looks like something's on like Katamari.
Grandpa would know Katamari.
the people are just spinning.
Wait, where is she?
She is there.
Where is she?
She's ruining everything.
No, no, no, no, we stay here.
We stay here.
We are in tutorial area where you spot.
Where did she go?
She's fucking, she's fucking doing Lincoln, uh, the I miss
you song.
Where are you?
And I'm so, so sorry.
Oh, she's, she's unmuted.
turn on her song she hasn't okay there's a three oh two one
go
she's back oh she's moving
Oh no, she had like no contest.
That's actually boring.
No, no, we said three, two, one, so she didn't hear us give
a countdown to it.
Don't worry, she's setting everything up.
Oh my god.
What?
I think...
She went to the right.
I have unused stat points?
Wait, did I level up from murdering Matara?
Wait, did you level up?
Does that mean you're level three?
Oh, no, you're level two.
No, you're level two.
You just didn't use your stats yet.
Oh, okay.
Turn it off, not turn it on.
Oh, I just got the hungry alert.
Oh, no.
Okay, we gotta start.
We gotta find some berries.
You go find berries.
I'll go with Matasay with Matara for a bit, just so she
knows.
Are we gonna use, like, baby's first base point, point,
which is, like, down there?
Yeah, let's just use that.
okay baby's first base okay matara i stay with you until i
stay you go no followers over here fix it
oh it's for making pal spears matara come on matara you got
this we grab berries do you know where baby's first base
point isn't it because i can show you i'm so hungry but i'll
stay with you until you fix your vc oh wait she wait she can
hear me i don't want to kill something do you have push to
talk on oh my god oh there you go voice muted yeah all right
come on let's talk oh my god i'm sorry no it's okay we were
like oh it's gonna be so funny matara said no pvp but why
don't we just turn pvp on with uh without telling i was
gonna come in and be like so you hate me huh and then just
instantly started beating me up a pack of wolves you're just
talking to a pack of wolves just yeah we're like we're gonna
babe attire to come closer with us dancing no that was
amazing that was amazing getting jumped on this street yeah
people wish that was them huh who how often do people say i
got beat up by four beautiful women and oh and i wish that
was daddy yeah and Granddaddy, look granddaddy.
We got brought grandpa in the power world.
We brought- Grandpa, is that lying?
No, that's not the- That's grandpa.
That's the easy mistake to make.
That's true, that's true.
You're practically Lymo's age right now.
Oh my God!
She's defenseless right now.
I didn't even hear her.
Is it actually on?
Oh, yeah.
Give me a call.
You really have bad patsy stuffy?
I'm going to be gentle.
I go get food now.
I have a bunch of food on you.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can I have some food?
Yeah.
Here.
I have an egg, too.
Oh.
I'm so glad we played.
This game is super fun, even though I got beat up.
It's okay.
It's part of the experience.
It's the initiation.
It's great.
All right.
Lime was setting up a base for us.
We should all join the gear guild.
Yeah.
All right.
How are you guys?
How's everybody?
We're good!
This is Min's first time playing Power World.
I showed her baby's first spawn point.
I just forgot to start the quest, so I'm running back.
Wait, we should all join the guild together.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, the unnamed guild?
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, you're...
I'm making you guild master.
Because I don't want responsibility.
Sure.
Okay.
Where do you take the bribes for being guild master?
Alright, name our guild.
They come in the form of gifted subs and do you want to mean
you want me to name something again name our guild Make sure
to join our join the guild.
How do I join the guild join the guild join my guild join my
guild join Give me an option.
Oh, uh, let me invite.
Can I wait.
Yeah join.
I can join Nimmy's guild Wait, no, no join Lyme's guild
right go up up top up top Lymo they can only join join
through your body Lymo I need your body.
We need your body It's so long, Taker, you say that.
Rammu's up top.
Also, Matai started beating up our granddaddy.
What do I get better?
My health is so low.
How do I just get the blood away from my screen?
You have to- I feel like I'm actually on my last legs.
Why not?
That's what it is to be old.
Hi.
I'm holding it.
I'm talking.
Okay, how do I actually manage the killed?
You were like, hey, go name it.
I don't know how to get there.
Oh, you have to go to your- Oh, I see it, I see it.
Yeah, okay.
Our sap guild and settings.
Oh, make me, you have to promote us from guests, by the way,
so we can start doing stuff.
Give us like the sub.
Members, okay.
Yeah, the second highest tier.
Admin privileges, please.
Yeah, admin privilege, please.
I will give you one bribe to kick somebody out.
Not me though.
I don't know.
I feel like Monkey's paw is in effect here.
Minto also join your guild.
Where do you get rocks from?
Oh, it's on the ground.
You just pick it up.
from the ground you can't granddaddy you can't beat up rocks
get not with your poor hands not with your frail hands so do
we keep the sisters part or the sloppy part are we sloppy
pals we'll be sloppy six sloppy six yeah that's actually
cute yeah there we go we are the sloppy the western movies
grandpa just leveled up
I'm gonna do this the whole time I'm sorry I'm really
feeling my grandpa RP I appreciate that you committed to
something and I'm so glad that you're finally like you know
making something of your cell oh did i not make mental
memory that wasn't personal let me do that it was just a
guess still oh there you go mental member all right sound
guys everything okay can also chat kid you guys all here
everybody i'm just beating up a sheep right now this looks
like we're at a gym everybody's doing like exercise we're
like one of those cards yeah how do you think we got like
Yeah, we didn't slack off grandpappy Everybody's so mean to
grandpa Respect is being an elder We don't respect your
elders I mean stone.
Oh, you have to chop down.
Oh, you have to chop down a stone.
Oh grandpa can jump really high We have to you have to build
stuff like there's a workbench that you can build things
Okay, I'm going I'm going to baby's first base right now
with Imo.
She has a workbench There's like a million workbench is
here.
Take your page All right, I gotta let's see it was What
they're going to crucify grandpa Can you do that in this
game?
I mean like you know me as well.
He's the oldest and the least productive Whoa Whoa midsummer
that's what they do grandpa's gonna have to jump off the
cliff bye grandpa you're of no use to the society of the
sloppy oh my god being an elderly person is so hard we're
gonna be called a sloppy five soon not before you're put in
the retirement home who killed one of you killed Mimi's
mascot lookalike oh wait a little elephant no look what a
baby killed it like your cousin wait do i hear us like a
special one yes there is it's right below me here oh my god
it's a giant chicken right here right here i pinged it wait
we all we i'm gonna look at some pal spirit and then we beat
it up and we catch it okay i don't see anything it's right
here i pinged him he's right here wait wait i'm not that you
don't see it oh oh no i see him i see him on the left on the
left oh see sparkles all right give me a sec i'll go five
i'm gonna get some pal spheres real quick you guys go get
ready all right all right let me go grab it oh these guys
are new Oh,
is the ping to attack?
Oh, I didn't know that.
That one's new.
Or maybe it's old.
I don't remember.
I've been using, I have a drag, for those who are new here,
I have a dragoon pal server.
Instead of using my pals to work, I use my dragoons.
I build something.
I just feel like dragoons build.
from the guy on up there don't worry also we fixed the lag
issue i forgot to schedule like server restarts and stuff
but we fixed the lag issues um because i just left the
server up without without ever restarting it but now the
server restarts every 24 hours
all right all right now we have some fried oh we got an egg
too
All right, do I need...
All right, I should be able to make some.
Yeah, so now the server is fine.
If you guys didn't want to do it because of the lag, the
server lag, is a lot better now.
Yeah, don't forget to open the survival yet.
Oh!
And grab some berries, and then we'll TP back home.
And grab this Paldian.
fragment and then we can construct some stuff all right oops
traveled the wrong one
what's the survival guide oh you go you press tap grandpappy
don't worry you press tab
did you did you get it yeah yeah yeah all right don't worry
grandpappy i got you i gotta go I hold F on this.
I need another hand.
Grandfappy.
Okay.
Grandpa's got you.
Don't worry.
Press F.
Grandfappy.
Press.
I'm doing it.
Why aren't you pressing F, Grandfappy?
I'm pressing it.
My hands just aren't as good anymore.
Did you take my... Grab, Papi.
Grab Papi.
Drop the... Drop the spheres, Grandfappy.
What do I do?
and then you you tried.
All right.
Don't make me get my dog here.
Grandpa's allergic.
And he's mad.
We all have to, okay, we all have to build this.
All right, hey guys.
Are you guys ready to beat up some chickens?
All right.
My dog's ready too.
Oh, that's joking.
Yeah, yeah.
All right, I'm back here.
Don't worry.
of my dog barking
Let's see are we all ready wait we'll swear for grandpappy
I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming Grandpaws Hey, no, no, no
Oh my god
at us don't you you good he's still biking he wants food no
no no no no all right are you all ready yeah let's go beat
up a chicken he's right here
i can't wait to get the chicken and do it on permanent ranch
duty go Get him up, get him up, get him up, get him up!
Do you really beat him up like that?
Yeah, beat him up!
Shoot!
We just beat him!
This is exactly what we did to Matara.
Yeah, it was practice.
Oh my god, he's ready!
No, he's not ready, we're fine.
No, he's not.
I can try and catch him, I'm gonna try and catch him now.
No, no, no, it's 73%.
Oh, that's good.
Nice.
Alright, we'll put him to work.
Yeah, we got him!
I'm gonna go catch a Pokemon what should we name our first
worker at the farm KFC okay I sure hope that you all ask the
same question of like oh did we just beat him up like that
when you were beating me she was our test subject or I'll
put I'm But put KFC to work.
All right, wait, I'm going to give dad a tree.
I'll be right back, guys.
Okay.
We're next.
Okay, do it.
Oh, he's swimming.
I won't.
You got to see your beautiful toes.
You can one hit.
One hit.
Okay.
I think I have a big nose.
I was wondering.
You have your toes out, too.
You always have your toes out.
I just stay out.
All right.
Wait, uh...
Lama, did you build a base station yet?
Where's that?
No, wait, it's just beyond.
What?
Wait, why can't you hit me?
No, because you took it off!
And no, I know it's because we're in the same guild.
We can't hurt our teammates.
Stupid!
But Ty, you know what?
You can leave the guild and just start beating her.
No, it's fine.
You could do that.
But you'll never know.
You'll never know.
Yeah, I thought you said you didn't want to do that to me.
The thing is...
The moment is gone.
The thing is, you'll never know when she'll turn off the...
Turn... leave the guild.
Alright, I'm gonna go...
Where's Lamo?
We need Lamo to set up a base.
Oh my god.
Why are you beating him up?
you use your stat points grandpa's got a level of uh and how
you go to press tab and go to look at the right and see
enhanced stats you got the grandpa it is part of the
tutorial by the way
we're just saying we're just saying i don't know this is
funny coming from mid he was like guys do i have to do the
tutorial we're like no no don't worry whoa who's so nice is
this
share i feel like i just absorbed somebody's xp no no oh
yeah yeah we have the xp share yeah oh that's why i love
that so somebody's who's t who's t finn is this oh that's my
little guy oh your little guy's trying to shoot me for some
reason all right i was like caving my starter pokemon's head
in with a pickaxe wait livo we need you to start up a base
station so i can uh put okay put the guy to work put kfc
away oh yeah where are we placing our pal station because
that's where the base is here here this is baby's first base
baby's first base where are you literally here perfect i
have the ingredients for it if you want we can all share it
i need one palladium fragment if anyone has i have it i have
it oh yeah you yeah nice i can stockpile mine i'll make a
bow i'm gonna put it here okay i put it slightly forward so
it gets this bit over here too which one Just show me where
maybe put it probably about here so it gets the whole area
Can you say please please do it.
Okay.
Oh, I have a applied lump.
Oh, why is it not letting me hold on Workload 10.
Oh, hold on overlap.
Oh, you do not have permission to place remove structures.
Oh, it's just We can place stuff, but not the pow box You've
been because pow boxes aren't you aren't good.
I'll do it here here here here leader only but you can place
everything oh we got about here right driving her can
someone beat the hell out of the elephant so get some of the
way but that's that's butara's butara's elephant yeah oh
thank you can I with the elephant I killed earlier oh he's
gone no he's dead yeah you have to like get him while he's
conscious he came out of the water yeah you just pulled his
body out of the No, he's dead, dead.
All right.
Get to work, KFC.
Yippee!
Hell yeah!
Hell beds will get stressed.
Wait, look at this.
Guys, look what I can do with my chicken.
Oh, no.
Chicken.
Chicken, come on.
Get over here.
Wait.
Chicken, come on.
Oh, you killed him, too.
Come on, chicken.
Oh, look.
Look at him.
Look.
Hey, that's my chicken.
They're found me.
Grandpa.
Oh my god, he's kidnapping my kitten!
Oh my god, he's rolling so far!
Okay, we need wood.
I just wanted to text my own strength.
Okay, why is your chicken so big?
Because he's the shiny.
He's a special chicken.
Oh, he's a special chicken.
He's just chilling.
He's so big and fat.
Yeah, and I can...
I can give him a little pet for death.
I'll be your first.
Oh.
I need that first.
Let's see, I need wood.
I chopped some wood.
I'll go build us a chest.
My chicken's just gonna roam.
Oh my arrow or something in order to kill this thing.
Wait, I'm just sitting there.
Fucking lazy ass chicken.
Why are you saying that about him?
He's just he's not doing anything.
He's not working on the farm.
Are we gonna die here because we it's going night and we're
gonna be cold?
No, we just put a fireplace.
Look at my guy.
Oh my god.
Look at that's you.
Look at my guy.
Oh my god.
Look at him.
Where you're naming him?
I killed it.
I'll go.
I didn't.
Did you just call him a go?
That's mean.
Why you said I was being mean of my chicken.
How do I make my guy warm?
He works to work.
He's ready.
All right.
Come here.
You place him in here.
You press F and press and drag it to Base Palace.
We only have like one spot right now.
So we'll let the ugly one work.
No, he's not.
Don't call that.
You literally call him Ugo.
No, it's a cute nickname.
Okay, we'll let Ugo work on the farm.
Drag your Ugo to the Base Palace.
It sounds like that kind of thing you'd say to a girl at
school and you're like, who are Ugo?
And she's like, what does that mean?
Oh, it means you're cute look at that oh oh my god i need
more we're gonna die here we're gonna get cold
what did you do to him what do you mean i'm trying to give
i'll go a chance to swim you can name your pal if you press
oh i'll build a fire i'll build a fireplace for us here i am
look look at It like fits because I'm so strong.
Yeah, you're so strong.
Alright, um...
You can name your pal if you go to tab and then, uh...
Okay, wait, what do I need for this?
Wait, I actually can't let go of him.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, you can.
What's your first palmon?
Oh, and he would.
I'm gonna make us a fireplace, so we won't freeze again.
I go to the tab, is that what I do?
Yeah, you have to put your pal back in your party and then
name it.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
it's time to start freezing.
Yeah, grandpa's.
Did you figure out how to eat in the end, by the way, guys?
Because I know how I can solve the problem for you.
Mom's going to teach us how to eat.
I'm hungry.
We have some white eggs.
Oh, wait, is this whose pal is that?
Is that random straight pal?
That's my pal.
No, that's mine.
He doesn't like when you chase him.
Stop and scare him.
My axe.
And then you're powering him.
I know it's not a wild how do you name your pal you press
tab and then you go to party and click on your pal And then
there's an edit option
Grandpa likes it when his pal licks him all Oh, yes, it is
you go party you press it and then you see your the name and
then you there's an edit on the top on the next to the
gender symbol Oh, I see stinky dokey.
Oh, I didn't I didn't throw mine out yet.
Oh, I'm dying
Dave!
Sorry.
Oh my god, she's downed!
Oh shit.
Grandpa's got you.
Don't worry, I got you.
Thank you.
How did you...
Oh, did you freeze to death?
I forgot to eat and I froze.
No, we won't.
Grandpa's little boy!
When you stinky snuff your stinky grandpa, hold on, I need
to get a stinky grandpa.
I will be right back.
Yeah, you can steal it.
You gotta make it though.
Yeah, grandpa's making you food right now.
Grandpa's cooking dinner for the girls.
This is how I used to make it back when I was in the force.
When you were, yeah.
Grandpa, what war crimes did you commit?
She doesn't want to talk about it.
Grandpa was never allowed out on the field.
Grandpa was never allowed to make war crimes.
After the incident.
They knew better than to lay grandpa out.
You can grab the big bears, Demi, you're still hungry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
All right, someone put their pal to work.
I'm gonna.
Okay, how do I put him to work?
You go, you need to party and drag it at base pals.
Oh my God, my, ew, he licking me like this.
Oh my God, he's so cute.
Gummy dachi.
Or gummy dachi.
He's a gummy dachi.
Oh my God, where do I put my, where do I put him?
How do I make him work?
Oh, you have to put them in the base.
All right.
Dragon.
Oh, it's only one.
Only one is allowed, so it's fine.
Because we're low-level.
We're low-levels.
Who's thinking me, though?
Who did that?
I have only one pal, so it can't be me.
I know who.
Who did that?
What's crazy?
That's crazy.
Wait, whose pal is this?
I don't know.
Whoa, who's this?
Whoa, what is that?
Whoa, no, I think that's...
Grandpa's little boy.
if you have one it basically like follows you all the time
and like you can't kill anything that you attack so it's
like good for catching oh it's a big counter whatever it's
called from the poke it's like a full swipe pokemon oh my
pal i see i'm pretty like a feeding station for the the
worker the worker the one and lonely worker i'm supposed to
unlock pal box technology i feel bad bro i'm gonna help them
out that's in your tab on your technology yeah yeah yeah i
got I'm almost mad at gaming right now.
Grandpa!
I just was trying to get more Pupparize and they spawned in.
Alright, let's see.
Yeah.
Can you give me money when you die?
Can I have food?
Grandpa downsized ever since the incident.
He lives frugally.
But Grandpa, don't you get money from the government?
No, Grandpa doesn't qualify for the government.
Grandpa don't qualify for the government.
The government doesn't qualify.
Grandpa committed tax fraud.
He's still paying it back.
Alright, upgraded.
We have two pals.
Oh, we have two pals working now.
Oh my god.
Anyone wants to... I'll make another bed.
Stinky, Stinky Minto is like aggressing on something and I'm
not sure why.
Yeah, Minto, you know, the little ones are always a little
bit aggressive.
Wow!
Wow, look at all this food!
I'm grabbing does anyone have extra stone?
We need stone for Yeah, let me put it in the chest.
I'm gonna put it in the chest I have 44 stone.
There you go.
Oh my god.
That's a lot of stone.
All right, we can plant berry farms now Wait, why is
something called stinky lime?
We're the stinky squad now The stinky sisters.
I know I'm still missing a stinky grandpa.
I don't know who grandpa doesn't they don't grandpa's
already stinky we don't yeah I'm not come stinky.
I kind of like grandpa and grandma smell.
Do you smell?
Wait like you know if ever you just have a new like the
scent of ponds cold cream is what you're saying.
I just like grandpa grandma smell.
I don't know.
It's like It's like laundry, right?
How many grandpas and grandmas have you smelled, Matara?
Just a lot.
What do you mean a lot?
Okay, but that's really real talk.
I did used to volunteer at an old boat home.
So a lot.
And you just smell them a lot?
You just like...
They have a smell.
Wait, how come you're very familiar with the smell?
Because I've had grandparents.
Yeah, but you have to be...
exposed to at least more than one like iteration so you know
for sure that i have two sets of grandparents oh you're
right now you're bragging live wow whoopty dude she has her
i had i had wait your grandparents didn't respond you're no
they forgot to said there's bond boy
We have, all right, I'm gonna go grab some, pal, I'm gonna
grab some fragments.
So we can.
I can hear her talking about, about grabbing.
My grandparents smell, yeah.
I'm gonna make clothes for once, so I won't freeze the
death.
I can't wait to get older.
I just feel tired at this distance.
I cannot wait to get older.
Proximity boys is really I could hear you like talking to
her when we originally went off to find this area It's just
like going into the distance Cut down trees.
Yeah, yeah, you cut down trees for fiber.
Okay I need to make a parachute so I need more cloth Making
a parachute over there.
Yeah, you just do cloth If you like follow if you follow the
quests in the top right it will lead you through like all
the basics.
Yeah, but like okay We're just skipping.
We're not reading instructions.
We just do.
Pupurai looks eager to help with the logging.
Thanks, Pupurai.
Good job.
Well, you didn't name Pupurai?
I could name Pupurai.
The problem is if I name Pupurai, I'm gonna name him
something like Leon, which is my dog's name.
And then every time he gets hit, I'll cry.
That's the best part!
Nintendo is working hard.
That's my girl.
Let's see.
I don't know who's called.
Oh, whoa, I need one.
It kills some more sheep.
I know, where are the sheep?
Ooh, I got it.
Did you see that?
What can I hear, like, shrieking?
Oh, it's the sound of the...
It's the sound.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, you guys are...
Oh, they're trying to kill sheep.
There's no voice.
Don't get away from me, Debbie.
What the fuck did KFC do?
Wait, why is KFC killing things?
KFC is angry.
It's because he's killing his own kind.
Chickens are like that.
That's true.
Are they?
Some chickens can eat.
Yeah, some chickens eat chicks.
Oh, I've heard about that.
Yeah.
It's survival of the fittest.
all right give him give him oh yeah oh yeah i need a cativa
oh shit oh my god he's missing kfc come on focus up
oh my god did he hit him did he hit everybody but i'm
grabbing the pupper
i'm grabbing somebody Somebody's coming in.
Oh my god, he's still chasing after him.
Yeah, I need to actually grab a sheep, though.
Alright, we can get the lamb though.
Yeah, KFC needs to hit a aim labs real quick.
Wait, I think...
Oh my god, he already killed him?
Oh shit, I did not mean for him to kill him.
Oh shit, he's killing everybody.
Okay.
Alright, we need to grab a sheep.
Yeah.
Alright, we actually need a sheep though so we can farm more
wool.
I mean, I'm still farming wool.
It's like, I guess.
KFC is going sicko mode.
I mean...
I mean, I guess.
I farm wool.
I got what I wanted.
I'm trying to catch sheep.
It's not my fault, KFC.
What's the fucking kill, sheep?
Maybe it is my fault.
Maybe I should send out the pup.
Oh, the deers are here.
Okay.
Oh, the fox is here, too.
I actually need more sheep, though.
uh okay these guys are good for oh wait these guys are good
for working at the farm
um there's no way he'll insta kill i don't think so it
should be fine yeah there you wait how a frog will do a frog
a frog is fine all right i have one more palace fear i'll
save I'm gonna go grab that checkpoint and then get back to
the home base.
You know what?
Just kill them.
Level up.
My little KFC.
A frog is fine too.
A grandpa frog.
What the fuck?
Alright, kill him.
Alright.
Give me your shit.
Alright, nice.
Give me your leather.
Oh.
We'll grab that paladin sphere.
Grab these rocks.
And oh, there's a dungeon!
A dungeon spawned next to us.
That's good.
Alright, what level is this dungeon?
Let's see, level 13.
We are not leveled up for it.
Oops.
I keep pressing E on these.
Alright, let's go back home.
I keep doing I'm back guys what's going on stop saying that
about bugs okay I should name why guys who's struggling yeah
who's what is going on mantis being stinky what's going on
Why are you struggling?
Mint is doing lamb genocide.
No, I'm not!
I'm not!
It's not!
It's definitely mostly accused!
Oh my god, I'm ready.
Google Doc is gonna show up soon.
No, it's not me!
I just want to go through the next day, Chris!
I also need to capture one more lamb ball.
You're not alone.
No, no.
She was trying to kill the lamb ball.
She's aiming the kill Is there something good for killing
them than capturing them?
Let's see, I need more air They don't respawn They don't
Yes, people tend to not respawn after you kill them Alright,
let me grab this bow Alright guys, the min situation is
crazy Actually, what am I doing?
Get over here.
Help me out.
What are you doing?
Why does grandpa's little boy not want to help me out?
What?
Okay.
He's supposed to be grandpa's little boy.
Grandpa needs an extra hand.
Maybe it's not your little boy.
He's grandpa's little boy.
Maybe there's another grandpa out there.
Some betrayal?
Grandpa betrayal.
That should name...
You get more wool.
What is that?
What am I frog?
Where did they even get that?
He's like down the street.
What do I call him?
What the hell?
What do I call this little guy?
Um...
I don't know.
Why should I call him?
My dragon.
He's my worker.
That's what you guys have.
But I'm making my arrows.
Wait, you're right, Kermit.
You have to kill, you can make a farm and then have a sheep
to work on the farm to provide wool.
That's the easiest way.
Oh yeah, frog wound.
I forgot my naming trend.
How are y'all doing with it?
yeah sheep seem to be in high demand however yeah sheeps are
getting absolutely murdered we're all looking for lamb we're
all looking for lamb i'm just making arrows oh that
shouldn't mean you walk close enough to it it'll it'll get a
star it'll start glowing can it be easier what she's just
like what
No, no, you're good no more
But shoddy bed right Just the leap stance I'm gonna upgrade
this a babe Oh, that must be my special move Froguna, why
are you not?
Oh shit.
Oh, that's what he did.
I flew guys Oh wait, who's frog is that?
That's my it's my frog.
He's here to help me It's froggoon.
I turned my dragoons into a frog.
Funniest shit ever.
Alright, we gotta keep making arrows.
He caught him.
Oh my god.
Froggoon, why are you not working faster?
Come on.
I don't pay you to work so slow.
Do you even pay him?
I said I don't pay him to work so slow.
He's getting exposure.
You should be grateful for the exposure I'm giving him.
Even fight him.
Alright.
Pen palladium.
Where does the palladium fragments come from?
You see those blue glowing stones?
You farm those, yeah.
I think it's because I gave them.
Alright.
You go keep doing your thing.
I'm going to go farm some stones.
I believe in you, Nimi.
Stones.
You can do it.
What is he me doing?
Unlock the blood lust.
Oh, is she still trying to find lambs?
Come on, girl.
Big blood lust.
You know when it feels like you got something caught in your
throat, but no matter how much you clear your throat, it
won't go away.
I got that.
Oh, that sounds terrible.
It's the worst.
Let's see.
How do you repair a weapon?
Oh, you gotta make a repair bench.
Do we have one yet or no?
Find this.
I can make one for us.
Grandpa needs to find a settlement.
Wait, do you have one?
Are you going to make one, Mint?
It doesn't let me.
Okay, I'll make it for us.
I have technology for it.
Okay, unlock the cloth technology.
It's a crap.
Wait, how do I unlock the cloth technology?
Just tell me.
Go to the technology tree.
Press T.
Oh, I see.
Yeah.
All right, here's the...
Oh, that's why you couldn't make anything.
Yeah, that's why I can't make literally anything.
Alright, there's a repair bench right next to this workbench
so you can grab it here.
Is there an easier way to get fiber?
Uh, no.
No, kill tree.
He just got a kill tree.
Oh god, there's no trees left.
They're all dead.
Yeah, we've like deforested it.
Yeah, just the usual.
Why do we have...
Why do we have five benches now?
because you'll have to make one for quest yes i'll yes don't
have to duke the quest guys yeah they give you instructions
for doing basic things we do have to do the quests and also
we can build more than one thing at a time like we can be
cooking like several things all right i need to make stuff
for the house the benches for days everyone has their own
Personalized Here I go All right, I don't have enough.
Look at those lumber acquiring arms.
They're so strong.
That's what those arms are for Grandpa's here too.
Yeah, grandpa.
We're all going to the gym guys I believe you questionable
all right I'm coming over Were you the scout for 40 years?
They let me start being grandpa at what age did you join the
war Which one yeah, which one yeah, which one grandpa is in
all of them Ram work, yeah Grand
See how do you what how do we up here?
What
all right let me do this parachute and then i can i won't
take fall damage anymore i miss having 20 dragons making
this for me i have to do my own work look at what i got look
at this guy all by yourself oh cute oh you got oh yeah he um
he gives you berries and stuff You can provide food.
I wouldn't have said by myself, Limeo.
It was a team effort.
No, no, I said all by yourself.
You did all by yourself.
You were very impressive.
You're taking credit.
All by yourself.
I did it all by myself.
Exactly.
Oh my God, we're all going to have clothes now.
Yeah, we're going to have clothes.
We won't freeze the dead.
Now you won't be naked anymore.
How does that fit on you, Doki?
I mean.
That's why I have no pants on.
Okay, fair.
I need pallidian fragments over there.
Grandpa has officially leveled up.
It's not, it's hiding too much of my arms, I feel.
I gotta level them faster so you can get the other outfits.
Oh, what level are you?
I think we're all the same level right now.
I'm pretty sure.
That's not true.
Grandpa's level six.
Wait, no, you're level seven.
I thought I was grinding.
Yeah, Matal is not possible.
You can soak it by yourself in the third person.
You never know when the youngins might surpass you.
Oh my god, it's making a shield.
Does anyone have scared palladium fragments?
I actually use one.
I put some in the box.
I have one, but I'll put more.
I'll help you.
Oh, you can help?
Oh, dang.
Yeah, you can assist each other.
It's nice.
Yeah, it's nice.
Don't take it.
I got it.
Thanks for helping me to sack the fuck off.
Yeah, I was gonna try to take it out.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, I have to equip it.
Okay, there's good.
And I gotta make a parachute too.
Logging site.
Oh my gosh.
Where do you get cloth from now?
Oh my gosh, now my dog.
You have to kill the sheep.
From all the sheep you killed?
Oh no!
I'm sorry.
You probably have all the wool still.
Let's see.
this?
Wait, do I have too much stuff in my inventory?
No, I'm good.
That's gonna scare all the pals away.
Yeah, he is.
He's angry.
I need more pals, I think.
I'm gonna have to give him his... What time is it?
Alright, he's gonna get his food early.
That's how I can make him stop.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
Are these just wild chickens?
Just a hoard of them?
Oh.
Yeah, who should be grandpa's second little boy?
Okay.
Not this one, not that one.
That one looks a little strong for Grandpa.
Yeah, he does.
He wins again.
He gets food early again.
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna go grab him.
Let's see.
I need a mount.
I cannot keep walking like this.
Alright, we got that.
Hell gear.
All right, it's time to get them out.
Oh, my Pupparize went to the box.
How does that work?
Is it like now our Pupparize?
What?
The box?
No, I think each box is like linked to your own party.
Oh, okay.
You could steal them from the PAL base, though.
You steal people's pals through the PAL base.
The voices, the voices.
All right.
my head i'm gonna go i'm gonna go get a mount okay i'm gonna
speed run it um girls does anybody still need a lamp ball or
are we all lampballed out all right guys i need it i need a
mount i can't walk this slow i've had it i don't get a dog
or a wolf i feel like i should get the dog uh i forgot all
right let's see oh my god granddaddy is traveling far Boys,
yeah, but dogs are faster.
I forgot about the slide tech.
I think I just used...
Alright, let's see.
I'm trying to remember how it's like over here.
And then...
Oh, look at all these Paldian spheres.
Yeah, I don't want to walk like a goddamn peasant.
Alright, nice.
I recharge.
all right there is but i read the wolves the fastest though
i like the wolf yeah i know they changed the location grab
the paladin c real quick and i'll come back to the crew i
just can't i can't be walking anymore i can't i'm too tired
of walking we like we like sped run our dragon server so
fast well as a team guys we all did it together remember
that um that I can't walk anymore I can't do the walking
thing I need I need I need to go fast technically we get the
bird the bird is also pretty fast yeah we did as a team guys
remember that it was a group effort
What do you mean still?
Like, I found...
I made this.
I made this shield.
What the fuck are you guys talking about?
I remember making it.
I'm trying to remember where it is.
It's, like, all the way there.
Is it here or here?
I actually don't remember.
Oh, I'm hungry.
Thank God I killed some some lamb earlier.
South?
Wait.
This way.
North South this way.
West.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm trying to figure out where the yellow forest is.
I need to find yellow.
Okay.
I need to find the yellow.
I'm going to show up with my dog.
And everybody's going to be like, Whoa!
Everyone's going to be so impressed.
Oh my god.
Everyone's going to be so jealous when they see the dog.
Okay.
Where's the yellow paint?
What is this?
Is this a...
Wait, this is new.
I've never seen this before.
I'm going to be so jealous.
I'm hacking Send power to all the panels How do I do that?
Oh
I'm in
What the fuck did I just picked up?
This is new Okay Where's the yellow?
Is there yellow over here?
Guys I don't see a yellow forest anywhere I see a chest nice
I got palace oh I got mega sphere but here next
to the village that's the church oh there's the church over
this mountain okay I see it I see the yellow forest all
right I see an egg too.
Alright, there is.
Yeah, I see it.
I'm gonna grab this.
And then...
Oh my gosh, so far.
I'm gonna grab over here first.
Hello, lambs.
Goodbye, lambs.
Camera grab.
This and then head over to the forest.
Oh, shit.
any of this oh I would capture him but I do not have enough
pals to do it I want to make sure I actually fuck it you
know what let's risk it I'm gonna say I don't know if I have
enough pals fears but oh let's try it
I got fast travel here anyway alright let's kill this guy
let's capture this guy where is he go 15.
it's
fine oh my god he's glitching he's gonna shoot my chicken
how the that hit like a hundred earlier
i don't think i need to yeah
There you go.
I'm just going to do that.
Oh, as I say, I feel like I don't need a scope in because I
can sort of tell where the headshot is.
They have a gun!
But he can't aim!
Oh, shit.
Oh, my bad.
He apparently can aim.
Whoops.
Call it too soon.
He can in fact aim
Oh my guys, oh my god, I can use my chicken as a meat shield
Oh shit, oh He's got to be shot by chicken
Oh my god my chicken guys, maybe I should not have used my
chicken as a me shield all right i'll just let him i
don't know what the percentage 17 that's not too bad i got
him yay we got man
man no my Chicken!
At least he has a gun.
Humans are not piled, therefore they do not possess.
Oh, shit, wait.
I wanted to kill this.
I wanted to whisp off.
Yeah.
Man, go get him.
Shoot him!
Alright.
Oh my god, you can stop shooting, man.
All right.
I got Whispa too.
I mean, finishing everyone's old Power Blots from two years
ago while I played, so this collab feels like the Avengers
team has sequel after watching everybody's standalone films.
They give them a genta soup, but they can thank you.
I'm glad you've been enjoying it.
Don't worry, I'll come back to the crew very soon.
I just have to grab a yellow... I have to grab a dog.
Man, you skill.
He used gun
There's the forest Sir eh, I'll come back to everybody.
Yeah, I'd have to put the chicken in the box So he could
heal, but I also need a dog.
I need dad 2.0
Hello, hello, hello Can Matara hear me from all the way at
spot?
I was like, what did she say?
Try talking.
I'm not even close.
Yeah, cooler, dad.
I don't know if I'll make this.
I don't think I'll make this, guys.
It's fine.
Where she can...
Yeah, I was gonna say, it's not too bad.
The most dangerous monster.
Man with a gun.
I'm gonna come back.
Guys, look at my new pal.
My new pet.
Guys, it's not slavery.
He chose to be in my...
He chose to be in my palisphere.
I mean, look at me.
Oh shit, there's the giant llama.
Look at my thighs.
It was a choice.
Amen.
I get it.
Alright, let's grab this.
Where the fuck are the wolves?
I'm in the yellow forest.
Where are they sleeping at?
Oh!
The server sat down.
What happened?
Oh yeah, the server just...
Loki, did you murder the server?
I don't know and I was just exploring The server just shut
down Oh, no It's not my fault I swear We're back in, we're
back in, server's back up Server's back up I literally was
just exploring Oh my god, okay Should I just rejoin?
Yeah, yeah rejoin The server's back up Okay, bye Bye, see
you guys back home
See, it wasn't my fault.
Not everything is my fault.
Yeah.
There's the dog.
Wait, they're shooting the dog.
Wait, I'm gonna let them shoot the dog so I can take the
dog.
Oh, shit!
Nice.
I'm gonna still shoot the dog.
The dog!
No!
me shoot the die all right well if the dog's gonna help me I
can get another
man oh shit that's not the man I wanted to get but I'll take
that I mean if he gets caught I mean good on me I guess shit
another man let's go wait where's the dog okay and then now
I need a dog oh oh shit
Oh, no.
Okay, it's fine.
Nice.
Okay, I got the dog.
Now I go here.
Alright, nice.
Wait, did he not get him?
Okay, he got mad.
Oh my god, and I get a chicken monk for free, too.
Alright, you go deal with a random man.
Man, I'm gonna go free him.
Alright, dad, you got this.
Yeah, I'm hungry, though.
I need to eat food.
Alright, did he kill him?
Good boy!
Who's a good boy?
Who's gonna get replaced soon?
What?
Whis.
Food.
Alright, nice.
I got two pals.
All right, now we have to find...
Let's see, is there a fast travel?
It is so far, though.
I need to go home.
I need to go home with everybody.
Okay, it's up top.
All right, we gotta go home.
We gotta meet up with everybody.
Oh, that's true.
That's an Ibu.
See, now I have the Ibu's.
Ibu.
all right let's figure out let's go to the fast travel and
head home meet up with everybody oh
my god let me up oh it's up here all right let's meet up
with everyone to show them what I got from my travels Jordan
thank you for the super chat he might not be a good boy
after that super chat
all right all right wow okay i was not expecting a fight up
here
all right let me okay let us head over here let them do
their thing all right dad get back here
All right, nice.
We're back home.
All right, we're in lock faster, fast travel.
All right, let's go meet up with everybody.
All right.
Wait, who's in the ocean?
Hello, everyone.
Hi, Doki.
I am back from my great journey, and I am here to show you
what I caught.
Well, not hit this guy.
house by the way it's a pup array yeah not this guy not this
side look what i caught everyone i call him man what hey man
what's up man you caught a man i caught a man guys he used
to sleep on the straw beds with the other pals why is he
purple what's going on with him he's just a little spec he's
a special oh i also have oh mint is dead in the water yeah i
was gonna say why is the water i was gonna look at the map
oh wait i'm dying we also have i forgot to eat
and i have a cooler man he also has a gun oh you found a
syndicate lug nice yeah your mom lets you have you got a
bunch of men yeah i have two i'm too cool men can't believe
your mom lets you have too and they work for me for free
Elliot man number two also have an i boo he's mine now
that's a that's an i boo an i boo yeah cute i boo i guess
i'll go do my quest thing i'll be back i'm going what
happened to mint how did mint drown in the water i don't
know how she drowned can she respond she should be can't she
respond give us a thumbs up yeah blink twice if you can
respawn I wonder if she can even hear us I don't think she
can I don't even know where whoa this is a great house guys
oh my god I built it with the sweat on my brow damn all you
Matara why are you taking Matara's credit I lost it all how
did you lose it all what happened I fell in the I fell off a
cliff and i went into the water hey look man i'll show you
something really cool that i have that cheer you up look
what i got how did you get that thing what is that i boo
what the hell that's right they're mine now they'll never be
yours hey man come and look at my stolen branding yeah look
at this man a man yeah i got i stole a man not only yeah he
was a good look i also have this yeah also i went on a
journey i went on a pilgrimage but wait i got a dog
grandpa's got something to show you too oh that dire hell
looks conspicuously like something i've seen before but it's
fine What a big boy.
Wait, where is Grandpa?
Whoa!
Grandpa's sad little man.
Why is he sad?
He's a sad little man.
I don't know.
He was born that way.
I lost it all and there's no supplies around here because
everything gets mine.
No.
There's mines everywhere.
What are you talking about?
Maybe you shouldn't have fallen off the cliff, man.
Maybe you should have been there for...
me what could I have done to prevent it please enlighten me
watch out watch out don't do she has her air pods on wait do
I have to remake my parachute oh my god no you can find your
body don't find your body and then you know you know I was
in the ocean.
You guys, I was, I'm, I'm in the ocean.
What happened?
Like, how did you?
Just go jump off the cliff again.
Can someone go get my, Doki, here's your turn to redeem
yourself.
What do I have to do?
Is that the pillar of light?
Is that my body?
Yeah, the pillar of light is your body where you died.
Okay, okay.
I, I ran out of stamina right before I got to a tiny rock
that would have saved me.
So if you see the tiny rock, that's my body.
Wait, no, it's right here.
There's your stuff.
They responded to it.
Oh my god!
Wait.
Oh, oh my god!
Yeah, I can't, I can't steal it too, because I have 23
minutes stuff.
You stole my stinking shield.
I went on a...
What do you mean?
I didn't, you said I didn't steal it.
No, I thought you didn't, and then I realized.
What do you mean?
Because the quest didn't happen.
What?
You're like, there's no PvP right now.
Yeah.
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna quit this guild and I'm gonna
I'm gonna murder you beatable when you quit good luck with
that I'm stronger than you have cooler dad no I'll get
coolest dad you're getting coolest dad who is coolest dad
wait there's gnarly me that's gnarly yeah gnarly nemi I need
a grub wait have you guys upgraded the base yet no we Give
me a crusher.
I can build a crusher for us.
I have a crusher.
A crusher.
It helps us get more.
I hardly even know it.
You building the crusher with those thighs?
Yeah, that's right.
You jealous?
No, I have arms.
Yeah, you can crush those things with your arms.
All right, I have the eyeballs working for me.
Look at that.
She's so excitable.
You think they're working for you, but actually.
What?
What are they doing?
They are working for me.
But actually what?
You think?
Grandpa loves all his children.
Hey, Grandpa's having his own little roleplay session right
now.
I'm just doing... I'm getting some...
What's Grandpa be doing?
Why is there a photo mode?
When you take pictures of your pals.
Oh, I don't know about that part.
Yeah.
Yeah, I need...
Oh, I still need more wood?
I don't even care.
Alright, how much do I need?
Oh, 389 is not...
Yeah, 5.
Oh.
What the... Oh.
She's still building up there.
I'm hard at work.
at work making us a home is there like a quick inventory
button or whatever like insert all those same items yeah
there is you go to uh just quick stack there's literally
quick stacks but there's only like oh oh i see yeah yeah
yeah there's a hole in our roof it's like a sunroof just cut
on fire what do i do you go to the water go to the water
grandpa grandpa it's okay you're not fire anymore yeah all
right i can build us a crusher now i'm gonna start crushing
stuff i have grenades grandpa's got a bunch of grenades why
does grandpa have grenades where's grandpa what is what is
grandpa doing oh my god for the war grandpa's sad little man
is helping me he might be sad but that doesn't mean he's
pathetic i taught him better than that he looks so like
careless about helping he doesn't want to be here you're
making him
you're forcing your grandchild to fucking work for you You
think he wants to be here?
Do we need...
Well, he's on probation, so he's got to be here.
Oh, we can make fiber here.
If you guys need fiber.
I'm going to start production on the Palkian fragments,
though.
Uh...
Okay, am I leveled up yet?
No, I still...
Oh, wait.
I can build something cool for us.
I think that you'll all love.
That'd scare you.
You mean it's gonna be super cool I need to get rural
grandpa's gonna go hunt
Oh my god are those for our solar panels Nimi I'm solely
focused on aesthetics right now There's that It looks like
somewhere where we could put solar panels on Oh my god
there's Halloween frog
oh my god now he's on halloween wait who has a cat tiva does
anyone have a cat tiva i have one oh neem you come over here
i can show you you can make your cat tiva even cooler oh you
see that statue over here yeah click on it
oh yeah sunglasses cativa yeah you could give him a sunny
glasses i gave mine a look when you give him sunglasses oh
cute weird grandpa sad little man he's much more happier now
what did you give him how do I you have to get hi here we go
grandpa sad little man he's no longer sad he's just he's out
he has a little party why is the frog is so cute yeah he's
like a yes Halloween now the frog is awesome I didn't
realize you're sad little man also yeah now he's here for
the festival he's wearing so cute yeah I had another one
that died he could he could wear something what do you mean
oh here we go here we go look at him gonna build a five he's
delicious grandpa's little boy Oh, he's tasty.
He's like decorative dessert.
Alright, let's see.
I have built a crusher for us.
And I think that's everything we need so far.
Alright, I need to level it up so I can.
Oh, POW box upgrade is available now.
Nice.
Alright, we can have more POWs.
The worth on the farm.
Okay.
Yeah, we- if anyone wants to add another pallet, this is
your chance.
Okay.
Actually, I can add- Is there something we need?
Wait, I'll add- I'll add Halloween frog.
Okay.
I'll add frogoon to the farm.
Um...
I'm gonna go kill some more of the sheep for the wool.
Making a roof is- Well, you could put gnarly Mimi in the
farm and then she'll make wool for us.
Excuse me.
We're gonna put gnarly Nimi into the farm.
You go, go.
What?
A gnarly wool?
Yeah, look, she's gonna make gnarly wool now.
Look at her.
That's her own.
How much wool does she make?
I don't know.
We're gonna farm her to find out.
We're gonna farm gnarly.
Oh, there she is.
Alright, let's see.
Oh my god, I don't know what men in lime were doing, but
they're like stacked up together and Matara
All right, let's see.
Wait, I gotta go on a journey over here.
I need over here too.
Oh my god, that was my little guy I got so scared.
I was like who the fuck's what's that giant thing back
there?
They're having fun.
What are they doing?
They're like my little boy Yes, I am little man I don't like
the way the side looks.
I think I should be like...
Shoot him, man.
Stop the tree!
How strong is your man?
He's level 8.
He has a gun, so he's pretty strong.
He has a license for it.
Ouch.
Oh no, remember to get in the water, Nimi!
I didn't know that this game has like...
Stop dropping wrong!
So grandpa got wanted by the police.
What is grandpa doing?
I think I shot at somebody.
down by the like the enforcers or something actually what
paint it yeah you can paint it you can paint yeah you can is
it gonna look good though or is it gonna look bad it's time
to find out neemie it's time to find out i'm gonna shoot
this drowning cat couldn't pick any color oh my god Hey
there little guy Wait, why are all our guys really mad now?
What's going on with them?
Oh, I think you scared them by drowning that animal on the
property.
Wait, did you paint it?
Mimi?
I painted upstairs.
How bad is it?
I don't know.
I don't know about this.
Oh!
This looks like we live in a playhouse.
Yeah, it's Mickey Mouse playhouse.
Other colors, is there, Nimi?
You can have any color you want.
Any color?
Any color.
That's part of the problem.
Too many colors.
Grandpa's making his new designer hat.
Oh, yeah.
It's so dang.
How do you paint?
Can I paint?
Oh, we get on.
It's under B and then push P. Oh, nice.
I'm very so close to leveling up so I can have him out.
Three guys.
The amazing digital circus is back.
Yep.
Oh my god.
Season two.
It's beautiful.
It's a sequel.
The circus is still here.
Here.
It does look like a Mickey Mouse playhouse now.
Yeah, it does.
Alright, nice.
Alright, now.
How much wool has it made?
How can you tell?
Has it done anything?
Uh...
It should have done something.
No, I think they transported it.
Oh, they did not.
I think he's so it's done nothing of value.
He's still making.
He's crazy.
He's still making it.
He's still, it takes a while.
Will takes a while to grow.
Yeah, I need.
Oh, we can make a hot spring now for our pals.
I gotta go kill more.
I gotta get Grandpa's hat.
Well, he didn't technically use it.
I just need pal fluid.
We need to kill.
Yeah.
Pal fluid.
It's like, we need their saliva.
It's farmable.
That obtained some fluid.
Let's see.
It's like any water pals produce pal fluids.
Oh.
Yeah, just...
Yeah, just some...
Yeah, I grab some fluids real quick.
Like high demand or something.
Nice.
Like give them a little bucket.
Technically speaking, you should just give them off of
killing any of them.
Someone was saying we found the lost McDonald's play place.
yeah oh it does look like oh my god oh my god that's so true
and also like a ball pit yes that's never yeah hasn't never
been cleaned since the creation of the play place kids love
putting those in their mouths we're killing everything we're
killing everything wait there was a second one i don't know
if i got it All right, come on, my pals.
Keep making my little balls for me.
Oh, my God.
I don't know where it's like loot drop.
Oh, you did a good job, guys.
What is he even fighting your demons?
You're fighting your demons.
Wait, what are you spending it on?
I'm making...
How much...
How much resources...
I'm going to go.
How much...
What resources does it take?
I'm spending the vibe.
Oh my god.
Limo, you're back!
How was the adventure?
Okay.
This is definitely enough for Grandpa's hat, so now...
Wait, Limo's...
Limo's...
That's PTSD.
I'm gonna look up the part and I'll finally get the respect
I deserve.
Yes.
That thing drowning?
Oh my god.
I thought...
When Doki said that thing was drowning, she was kind of
joking.
Limo...
Limo, can you hear...
I can't hear that!
Wait, I might have to come back to the server.
I'll be right back.
I was gonna say, why couldn't Lymo hear us?
Alright.
Are you now?
Oh, I can hear you.
Yeah, it was your server.
I was like, does Lymo have PTSD or something?
No, no, no, no.
Look, look, look, look what we got.
Yeah, what did you guys get?
Oh, you guys fought the chilling.
Yeah, we got the ferret.
Look at him.
He's so cute.
Where is...
Matara Min help me.
Yeah, I was going to say, where's Matara Min?
Why are they...
They are still over there, I think.
Yeah.
Yeah, they're still over there.
Belaya, did you find any leather on your adventures?
Because I need to.
No, we need to go kill those dickhead boars for leather, I
think.
I can go find some.
Yeah, I need some.
Yeah, I don't have a spawn point for that.
Okay, I will go find some dickhead boars.
I'll be right back.
Yeah, thank you.
I need, like, two leathers.
You need to come back from your travels, from your
gathering.
Oh my god, you made a bar!
It's really nice in there.
Yeah, it's beautiful.
You have a car?
No, it's a bar!
Grandpa is getting hard in here.
Yeah, Grandpa needs to turn on his ears.
I'm sorry.
I don't know if I just got guns.
I thought a car in this game was just something that was
gonna be normal.
Honestly, yeah, I wouldn't be so much.
Yeah, if there's guns, there's cars.
No way, Grandpa's making a pole.
Yeah, it's not completely out of the realm of expectations.
look let me make a bed for one of the pals before i leave
because they're gonna get stressed apparently oh yeah we
need another bed i need let's actually if you want to make
the bed i will go find a mother all right i'll make the bed
then all right see you in a minute all right thank you like
grandpa's new hat oh yeah it suits you what do you mean as
the architecture of this home we mind it's just a pal bed we
don't care about that the pals will sleep against the cliff
we're gonna revolt against you for being a terrible person
what do you mean that's right you sleep behind the house
should have raised you later you don't want we don't want
the pals to lower the property value so they have to sleep
behind the house oh my god we gotta we gotta a bougie up
there living quarters then that's what it is we can make a
barn oh that's true let's make them sleep in the barn is
this gnarly neemie farming for us still oh gnarly neemie
wants to sleep i do always oh yeah she did wait we have one
wolf she gave us one wool guys
All right, let's see.
Yeah, they're outside, pals.
You can go to sleep.
Oh, no way.
We're going to need more beds, actually.
I should have made a bigger house.
I thought I was making a huge house already.
Oh, you can add like a shed to the side.
Like a little shed.
Oh, I forgot I'm meeting!
Bunk beds.
That's true.
I don't think there is bunk beds, though.
I'll make it happen.
It's like a double-decker couch.
Yeah, exactly.
Making a little power station for us.
So if you guys see that...
We're gonna make carpets, but I have to go kill something
that's venomous.
Uh, I don't know.
The grandpa's in her hands.
Gonna hunt for some carpets.
alone.
Did someone make another...
Can I make another chest yet?
No.
I'll make another chest for us to put stuff away.
Technically, the thing behind the bar is a chest, although
it might be kind of hard to reach.
Wait, was it?
The shelf?
Oh, yeah, it is.
Alright, I'll put some stuff away here.
Alright.
Guys, I'm putting a thousand dollars.
dollars in the wooden shelf so I hope it doesn't get stolen
and some eggs too.
Oh yeah, do we have an egg incubator?
Not yet.
We don't have enough levels for it.
Oh.
A dog coin.
Not the Bitcoin.
Not
Let's see.
I'll put all the eggs in here.
I'm investing in dokey coin.
Oh, I do have a dokey coin though that you can actually
invest in.
Really?
Yeah, yeah, it's on tokymerch.com, guys.
Don't worry, it's not a rug pull.
What is the value of a one-only coin?
Well, well, it's up to you guys.
If you invest, you'll find out.
You know, you have to invest to find out.
You gotta buy, you gotta hold, and then it will go to the
moon.
Exactly.
Well, it's gonna go to the moon, guys.
Not a rug pull.
In fact, I would say it's worth more than a Canadian dollar
right now, which isn't saying much, but...
It's worth more than a Canadian dollar.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, there is a sword button.
I keep forgetting the sword button.
It's been so long.
Yeah.
Like a feather for some reason.
Oh, all my stuff is broken You gotta repair it I should
repair mine too Uh, oh yeah, my axe is about to break
Where is Oh my limo and granddaddy are traveling together
Are you looking at them on the map?
Yeah, yeah, they're holding hands We should do the big bar
Oh, we should.
Wait, I'll do it all together.
Yeah, I'll grab everybody.
I think we're all leveled up.
Are we ready?
Yeah, I don't think we're ready.
We're so ready.
Are we?
Yeah.
Alright, alright.
Alright, I'll call everyone.
Let's do the big raid.
The big boss raid.
I think we're so ready for it.
I mean, there's like...
My chat is saying we're...
We are so ready.
No, we are so ready.
Wait, if your pal dies, does it die forever?
No, no, no.
Your pal stays with you.
We actually need the... I'm still waiting for Lama to give
me the...
Give me leather.
Wait, I'm gonna grab leather.
I'll be right back.
Emergency meeting!
No, the first big boss.
The tower guy.
I think we're so ready for the tower.
Does Dairwolves give you...
Well, let's try to find out.
I don't know if Dairwolves gives me the letter, so I'm just
gonna test it out.
Okay, yeah.
You do.
I'm just gonna kill all of them real quick.
What the fuck?
Where did this Hedgehog come from?
In the middle of all of them.
I guess they were in the mid-hunt or some shit.
Remember when I used to 360 that?
Woo!
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Alright, I didn't need to wait for a live move.
Yeah, Sonic.
How did I feel Sonic?
You took too long.
Oh.
Hey, guys.
I'm back.
Hi, Boki Bird.
I got leather.
Lamo took too long.
Guys, we should do the big boss, the first big boss
together.
Big boss?
Which one is the big boss?
The first one.
Do you mean the tower?
Yeah.
Okay, cool.
I just got the fast travel so that works.
Yeah, we should do that.
Okay, let me grab leather real quick and then I'm ready to
go.
Hold on.
I need my balls.
Let me get some more balls and arrows.
Well, we don't really need balls, though, for...
no but i like i like to have some balls oh you like it's
always good to have some balls you don't want to pre-ball it
hey we're gonna go fight big we're gonna fight big boss oh
my god excited i have to make my feathered hair band first
and it's taking a long time yes gotta look pretty for big
boss exactly how was your adventure matara what do you guys
do we went and killed something for Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, Larry told us you guys see the house Mimi builds.
It's so pretty.
It's beautiful.
You should check the inside.
I know.
I saw the bar.
Yeah, there's a bar and everything.
Yeah.
I didn't see the bar.
Grandpa's going to go get himself a drink before the day.
You should, Grandpa.
You should.
Oh, no, they said only four at a time.
For what?
So two can go two and four, basically.
Wait, I am so sorry.
I have a question.
One of my guys says, your dropped items plus 50%.
Does that mean I get 50% more random item drops?
What does that mean?
That's what I'm asking.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Oh, oh, yeah, you get more items dropped, basically.
Is it your pal that's in your inventory?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like each pal has a special effect.
So if you go to your pal, you steal it.
description being like oh um service-minded what they can do
yeah they can do service grandpa already did the service
thank you for your service grandpa okay so good news when we
butcher that one it will give us oh do we want to do the
tower is three and three by the way hey we did three and
three yeah okay i'll build it I'm grabbing right Well, I
need to grab my mouth An old antique rug into the bar.
Oh, you're not rogue.
I want to eat.
Yeah Oh nice grandpa Yeah, this was a hand me down from
Great grandpa the great grandpa.
Wait, hold on.
I have to like I have to I have to do this Do what?
Be a grandpa Yeah.
You're like a cat.
I have to honor this area.
Everybody just drops dead.
I think there's a CO2 leak actually.
Wait, your fucking frog is stealing my food as I make it.
Go away, Fergoon.
Fergo is hungry.
The rug that makes me sleep.
The rug that makes me hungry.
It's like the...
Oh, it's like in Wizard of Oz?
The Wizard of Oz, there's the poppies or whatever.
Yeah.
The poppies are laced with, like, chemicals.
You know, we are an alcohol.
Yeah, oh, yeah, the asbestos poppies.
What?
Yeah.
Yeah, so, like, okay, you guys know how the Wizard of Oz,
the original Wizard of Oz film was so fucked up and lots of,
like, not really legal stuff that they did there.
And one of them was that, when it started, like, snowing,
they used the...
asbestos oh yeah and they use like real metallic paint on
the tin man no no not not not human safe paint oh my god he
was fine he just got a little sick yeah it was not the best
work environment yeah the first there was a another actor
originally that's supposed to play a tin man and he was sort
of like the test subject and it wasn't good for that guy
though it was worse for him yeah oh look guys was it good
for anybody i'm ready to raid i'm ready to raid i have three
three how should we divide the teams i think maybe lime and
doki captain of each team because you girls are pretty good
and then mint and neemie on each team and then grandpa and i
feel why is there Hi.
Gumi, a pudding now.
Sorry?
All right.
How are we going to do this?
We can also keep me and Ninto together.
I don't mind.
I was just figuring since they're both...
Wait, that's your grandpa.
That's not you.
That's not, this is Lai Mo.
Sorry.
You guys both have great hair.
I thought you just wanted to give grandpa some code.
I have a way that's going to fix this problem without
anybody getting upset.
On the count of three, we name somebody we don't want to be
on a team.
We're not.
Based on, like, who do we least want to be on a team with?
That's definitely not going to upset anybody, yeah.
Guys, look at cooler dash, guys.
Look how cool he is.
Come on.
Is he pretty cool?
He's pretty cool.
Yeah, he's pretty cool.
Look, he can spit on you.
He can spit on you.
Where'd you get him?
Because he's cute.
I want one.
You got him in the woods.
I adopted him.
It's my first day playing this team.
This thing.
Yeah, you're doing great.
I'll get a randomizer.
I'm getting a randomizer.
Perfect.
name randomizer all right let's see i'm gonna generate the
names now what do i what does grandpa need like a gun no
it's not a woodwork yeah bow what did you use in the war
yeah what did you use i've got fire arrows all right nice
randomize I fucked up.
I forgot to put Limo in.
I forgot I don't got no feeling items.
I have to randomize again because we were both on the same
team.
And now we're both on the same team again.
And then we're both on the same team again.
They keep putting me and Limo together.
Oh, there we go.
It's- They want us to be together.
It's fate.
All right, group one is Snuffy, Matara, and Limo.
Group two is me, Mint, and Nimi.
Okay, wait.
Am I crazy?
I was not on the group site server.
Twitch versus team YouTube.
All right, let's go.
Okay.
Wait, hold on.
Yeah, it's like Twitch versus Team YouTube.
Yeah, Twitch versus YouTube.
Whoever finished first.
What?
We don't all have the boss trouble.
That's not fair.
Can I pee while we do this?
Can I pee?
No, we'll be slower.
Guys, guys, come on.
Guys, we gotta go now.
We gotta go now.
I don't even know how to find the boss.
Grandpa's going in.
Where am I going?
I'm gonna go fast travel there and then, Grandpa was in the
ward and knows how to win
Hello, hello, all right now.
Okay, so actually two of team twitches here you team you two
might be struggling slightly.
Oh shit Wait, it's my it's my Matara went to peace.
Oh, she's gonna be god knows how long Go to where I go to
where I am In the map on the map
Wait, they don't have the TP wait No, they don't Oh, no!
Alright, don't worry, I'm coming over!
I'll meet up with them.
Come on, guys!
Team YouTube!
Wait, where are they?
Guys, come on!
Team YouTube!
It's them here, I'm here, I came back because I realized you
don't have the fast travel.
Yeah, thanks!
Alright, guys, follow me!
Matara's still peeing.
Fast travel?
Yeah, yeah, that's the fast travel.
You should click.
Oh yeah, Nima, you're building a house.
I forgot.
You did not come down here.
All I did was build a house.
Oh, you guys was fast travel to here?
Yeah.
All right, all right.
You follow me, guys.
Don't worry, don't worry.
Matara's still peeing.
We still have a chance.
Okay, okay.
I don't know what's going to happen to us.
This is too much pressure.
We got this.
We got that, I believe in us.
Don't worry.
have a bow and arrow is depending on all of youtube is
watching what is this oh yeah yeah pick it up pick up it's
for uh the more you have the easier you can catch pals wait
me how many pals do you have six that's good that's good our
sheep oh that's okay that's okay all right come with me is
there i think but you see that that thing over here like the
blue thing that's where you have to it's a big tower up
there okay there's another fast travel too yeah yeah yeah
that's the fast travel yeah that's where we got this guy
there's an egg up there can i climb real quick wait where
are you going oh to the egg i was following you man we kick
we can we get the egg after mint okay all of youtube is
depending on us you got promise we're gonna delete our
channels hey batara
Oh Boss, I'm following I'm following live
Which way go go go go get out get out get out go go How do
we join in the same way doing though?
Wait, click on it.
You guys all go in first go in first together.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm going in Wait, I can't go in.
Why can't I fucking click on it?
Haha, haha, you can't click.
Oh, wait.
I can't actually click on it either.
It's just locked.
Wait, why is it locked?
Oh, no, no, it doesn't say lock.
Wait, other players are cool.
Who's inside?
We're all by ourselves It's just there.
Did we send them by ourselves?
He actually started the boss.
She's the one not sweet.
Oh wait, it's Numi there too.
It's Numi.
Okay.
They got this.
That's so funny.
Good for them.
I guess it's us four now.
Yeah.
That's fine.
Fuck your randomizer, whatever.
The NDB are in there.
All right.
They're going to do great.
Don't worry about it.
I believe so funny.
She really wanted to meet big boss She really did It was
very important to her My god your chill it is so wait I have
to do the quest lovely No, you don't you don't have to do
the quest to actually get in here.
Yeah, I was gonna say it It's just because they started the
fight.
I told them to go in and they started they spammed it so
hard that I couldn't do
I wonder if they're doing okay.
Oh, hey, you have my wife.
I do.
I'm gonna go in.
You got a big one, too?
Yeah.
Look, yes, you got.
So cute.
Yes, she's less depressed.
How many people can we have in the dungeon is also four?
Everyone's got a big one, but me.
Yeah, we could we could do a dungeon while we wait.
That's true.
Let's just do the dungeon, guys.
Let's go do the dungeon while we...
They can't go in because it's 4 max.
Alright, let's do the dungeon.
Dungeon time.
I like to enter the dungeon.
Grandpa is entering the caves.
Apparently, apparently they're halfway done.
Halfway.
Yeah.
They're doing it.
I've always believed.
Yeah, I vote.
Oh my god.
Is this where you caught the men?
You don't know there's men everywhere, but you can still you
can catch them.
Why do the dungeons run like shit for me?
Oh my god, you caught him.
I caught a syndicate thug and he's an ace swimmer.
Yippee.
Yeah.
You can catch the guy here.
Swim.
Wait, catch him here.
They're doing it.
A paramee is carrying.
They're gonna be so confused as to where we went.
Where did they go?
Oh, that's a big void.
Why are there so many syndicate thugs down there?
I'm gonna grab some of the fragments.
We should mine the big pelagia.
Yeah, yeah, you can mine these for more ore.
Wow,
that's really badly for me.
Oh, that's weird.
Oh, they killed Nimi!
Oh, they got me!
Oh, the sheep clutched it!
Maybe Mint can revive.
Yeah, maybe Mint can revive, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, the boss is over here.
What is it?
Let's just go straight for the boss.
This is almost done.
Yeah.
Oh,
apparently Mint Clutch revived.
Mint Clutch revived.
Nice, nice.
They did it!
They won!
Yay!
They're going to be so confused as to where we are.
It's a cremice, apparently.
Oh, I want one.
It's like an Eevee.
It's a totally not Eevee.
I'm going to grab the little ones.
You can grab the big...
Whoever doesn't have a big one yet should get it.
I don't have a big one.
Which one is the big one?
What do you mean which one?
Is this one the crevice?
Is this one?
It's the one that Lamo is fighting right now.
That's the biggest.
Wait, hey!
Who's catching the crevice I was supposed to catch?
Somebody killed the crevice!
No, no, the big one.
It's a free-for-all!
Lamo is like, I don't care!
It's a free- Mine!
Big Matar.
It wasn't even that big.
You were catching up so too.
Would you like the cremice?
Would you like the cremice Matar?
Oh, my God.
Yes, actually, I would like it, please.
Hello, you guys.
We're down.
We're doing the dungeon.
And we heard...
Wait, where is it?
It's above us.
Jump down!
You won't die.
For a second, Matara, I thought you were beating the shit
out of your own pals in a rage or something.
I was like, girl, if you're gonna hurt anything, hurt me.
What the fuck?
I died!
Did you see what happened?
Wait, did he die?
Wait, I have somebody who can do CPR.
You're not dead.
We can see.
We were five.
You guys did it.
We did it.
You guys spammed the dungeon so hard you forgot to let me
in.
No, it said two out of two.
No, it's maximum four.
No, it said it said it said two out of two.
That's no no no way.
There's no way.
What's with the name on your hamster?
It's grandpa's kinda sad.
Congratulations!
You guys- Yeah!
They were giving us updates!
Wait, how do I heal my Pokemon now?
Um, you just keep your inventory and feed them.
Oh, feed them, okay.
They gradually heal.
Matara, come over here!
We- it's our turn to do the- do the thing.
What thing?
Oh!
It's our turn to do the boss, the big boss.
Are you sure- Are you sure you don't want the premise,
Matara?
I'm gonna double check.
Because last time I did it, I can- I had like four.
people with me in it okay okay no it didn't lie to us we
just ran yeah i give you a kiss guys it it says one out of
four why didn't you join us you joined because you started
you clicked on it it's back started you with all the
screaming what did you say i said kiss kiss kiss kiss kiss
oh okay kiss kiss kiss kiss but congratulations i heard i
heard you did clutch revive on emy Technically, YouTube won,
because, like, my YouTube crew won.
Is that how that works, huh?
That's how it works.
My YouTube crew got it.
Let's go murder it.
All right, come on.
We're waiting for you guys.
Oh, there's a dungeon over...
There's a dungeon over here that you guys can do while you
wait for us.
Go in the cave?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go in the cave while you wait for us.
Okay.
I think the premise is in the box.
It's in the box.
Are you guys ready?
sorry how does this work okay so don't hold it until we're
all joined don't hold what so just press f on this on the
tower there we go and now we begin now we begin yeah yeah
sorry i'm i'm old no you're beautiful isn't
that beautiful whoa you can catch her later but not now
because yeah you can you could catch her for our base Oh.
Yeah.
She's a bad girl.
Grandpa's gonna catch me a baddie.
Ooh.
Aqua baddie.
Whoa.
Can you catch that?
Can you steal her Pokemon?
Not in this fight.
Oh, dang.
Yeah.
Yeah, she's a baddie, baddie.
I don't know if you can catch her multiple times.
Is there supposed to be music?
Oh, wait.
I made a minute.
It looks like a leg of the park.
Not Electabuzz.
There was a three-three Pokemon that actually looked like
just like him.
Zanguish.
It's like an Electabuzz and a Zanguish at the same time.
Ah.
Oh, oh, wait.
My chicken's hungry.
Give me a second.
Let me feed him.
Oh, you frozen.
I'm mid-feeding my chicken.
He's no longer hungry.
He doesn't know where you're going to participate.
see oh no can't see go where i'll send a man over he's gonna
start shooting he has a license for to carry arms i don't
know if i can even burn with a pistol my children appears to
be stuck in the floor he's almost dead why is like my pals
tanking everything oh sad little man is actually tanking i
forgot i was put the nerve because weak point is the the
lady on top shoot the lady oh i didn't realize it was like
freaking there's like weak points yeah there's a lady on top
of the pallia shooter oh i was shooting him i wasn't gonna
do violence again hot woman hot boss mommy oh she's about to
go down sad little man we did sad little man die He died for
this, he died for this.
Cut down in his prime.
Sad little man.
We did it guys.
We're gaming.
Grandpa just leveled up.
Yippee.
Wait, I love this name, Limes and Leon.
I'm so close to flipping fishing.
That's my greatest target.
Grandpa just wants to be here and to fish.
wait i'm actually so far from it but you and i are the same
sorry did you want to come back to the base and get get
kremis yes okay okay let's do that let's do that if you jump
down from here you won't die oh bro i experienced phantom
with my drag wounds okay i did do it yeah wait
where did everyone else go do it they jumped they believed
you yeah i believe they trusted you i told you thankfully
grandpa had it i jumped had his penicillin so matara why
aren't you jumping i jumped matara's jumping i'm here i'm
jumping enemy i am drowning under the water she's just here
yeah she's here we get to talk to you
What do you mean?
I'm right here!
I jumped just like you!
I literally did what I told you to do.
I just got a key sphere!
Whoa!
It has my stats.
Okay.
Matara, I'm heading back to the base.
Come get your Kremis.
We're all heading back to base.
Wait, are they still in the dungeon?
I think you're lost in the dungeon.
Oh.
I want to check up on them.
Are they actually in there?
Oh, yeah, they are.
Are you guys in the dungeon still?
Hello?
Where are you guys?
Oh, my God.
How do you guys even get out of there?
We walked down here.
Oh, you walked down there?
By the way, we forgot to mention there's no more loot in
this dungeon because we already...
Wait.
No, I got a chest.
Oh, you got chest?
Oh, like from...
Oh, okay.
There's no bosses left.
We killed the boss, so it's just...
I think we left all the loot, though, so you can explore it.
We just went straight for the boss because we saw you guys
all were done.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, so there's a bunch of loot still around.
I'm gonna grab this cat real quick.
Yeah, we both got cats.
Yeah, I want this cat too.
Alright.
We'll kill that guy.
I have enough palace spears for this.
Oh.
Oh, whoops.
Alright, nice.
And then...
Honestly, you could kill that one.
Cooler, Dad.
I can kill them if you want.
All right, go get him cooler, dad.
That's right.
All right, come on.
Come on, cooler dad.
Come on.
Oh, I got money from the cat.
A cat is fine, too.
Yeah, I know about the five.
It used to be ten.
Hey, guys.
Wait, where?
Oh, yeah, if you have a mount, there's no fall damage.
A mount?
Yeah, like a...
Oh, like your dog?
Yeah, yeah, but there's different types of pals that you can
ride.
Where'd you find that dog?
It's in the forest.
I can get you guys a dog.
I want a dog.
There's a dog.
You can get a dog, a boar.
Oh, the ferret also is a mount, too.
You want...
What?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The one that Limu has?
Yeah, you can use it as a mount.
So you guys want a dog, a pit boar, or a ferret?
I kind of want the ferret.
I'll kill that ferret then.
I did it once.
I can do it again.
Yeah, we can do that.
Alright, let's get you out of the dungeon.
Okay, it's...
It should be here.
Yeah, it's here.
Oh!
There's the tree.
We already killed the...
The boss in here, so...
So it's free now.
What was it?
It's like a little Eevee.
Did you capture it?
Yeah, Limeo has the big version.
I have the little guy.
Wait, Man's Trust increased to one.
How did Snuffy die?
Wait, Snuffy die?
I saw I said that grandpa had died.
No, it's grandpa's sad little man that died Oh Okay I was
like, my bad My total mistake It's a sad little boy, not
grandpa Oh my god, I accidentally used my mouth I was trying
to leave
Oh, it's my time Oh, is it?
Alright, you guys want to go grab?
You guys want to go grab?
grab uh the ferret i actually have to be going that one this
thing you know what oh that one is a mount too whoa wait
that's cool all right let's wake him up i only have one
pal's fear though all right we gotta get him low he's your
one chance there's two of them there's not one time go do it
do it do it do it do it do it do it do it do it oh oh Oh!
Oh!
I don't have one.
Sorry.
I have one.
I'll give this to you.
Thank you.
Yay!
Do you want one too, man?
Yeah, I want one too.
Let's kill this one.
All right.
I can separate here.
You can have one.
We'll try it again.
Whoa!
You minted the power sphere.
There's the power sphere right here.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
One shot.
Oh!
Where did he go?
It's over there.
Not yet, though.
All right.
Okay, wait.
One shot.
Come on.
Oh!
Oh, yeah!
Yeah!
All right, let's go home.
Let's go home.
Yippee!
You said you were going to keep the server up so that we can
play it off?
Yeah, it's dedicated server, so anyone can go in.
Yay!
Yes, yes.
So you guys want to play more later.
It's for one month.
but it won't play longer.
I can extend it.
He's just like...
Oh, wait, they did a dungeon?
Wait, they're back.
They're back.
No, the dungeon was...
The dungeon had nothing inside, but I was just, like, trying
to get them out of the dungeon.
Hey, we're back.
I'm not fired.
All right, let me go back to it.
Roll, roll!
Roll!
Wait, does that actually help?
No.
Wait, why is your...
wife so so anime you grab the deer now from the pal box from
babes pal and put it in your uh inventory okay okay i can
steal him yeah you can steal him what don't steal him yay
now wait where do i put it uh you can put okay i just
replaced one of my other you guys i should probably go to
bed it's like two in the morning yeah i had so much fun
thank you yeah we should play more the server is gonna be up
for an entire month so if everyone wants to hop in yeah
let's do it again yeah i want to i want to play specifically
with you guys so i want to make sure like we need to like
figure out when we all hang out yeah yeah we can do it like
next week after your off guy and then yeah yeah just let me
know let me know and i will join yeah let's go gt's everyone
okay gt thank you everybody
Grandpa.
Shout out to Matara for organizing the collab.
I love Grandpa.
Bye everyone.
Shout out to Matara for organizing it.
I like that name Matara.
That's very nice.
It's the doggy for the server.
There's no problem.
Thank you doggy.
Bye everyone.
Bye bye.
I'm going to get on my horse.
Wait, come back.
Wait, my horse is running away.
Wait, how do I get my horse?
Are you going to get your whole horse on the all time road?
You gotta be level 12.
You gotta be level 12 to make a saddle.
So you go to technology.
And then you see the saddle for it.
Oh, okay, okay.
I'm almost there then.
Yeah, and then you have ride the deer.
Yeah.
Already?
Yeah, we caught a deer for early ride on.
Yeah.
That's fun, everything.
I love the voice proximity.
It's so nice, too.
It was a lot of glitching out at the beginning a little bit,
but it's better.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I had that glitch, too, where you hear...
hear other people and can hear someone else.
At the beginning, like, I thought Yoki was just really much
louder than everybody else.
Grandpa made you guys this hat.
A feathered hair man.
We're gonna miss you, Grandpa.
Oh, hold on.
We'll be pretty and then I'm gonna leave, I promise.
I promise I'm gonna leave right after this.
You're not gonna, you're gonna grind, you're gonna grind.
We're gonna walk back in and be level 100.
You're gonna grind.
Yeah, you're gonna play with us.
That's the, without you, yes.
I mean, uh, uh...
What?
Wait, wait, where is grandpa's young mistress?
Oh!
Wait, where is it?
Where is grandpa's young- Oh, my goodness!
Oh, grandpa!
Hey, grandpa!
Grandpa enjoys the fine things in life.
Where's grandma?
Wait, you know, grandpa, all grandma has left in this
relationship, you say, I have- Yeah?
Yeah?
here we go this is grandma this is what grandma left me you
know she left me grandpa's grandma's widowed garden oh wait
why are you gonna call your deer mint oh um deer oh dear
just a deer whoa he's just out here chopping things up damn
look at him he's going He's on the X-Men.
Grandpa, I hope you feel better, Grandpa.
Wait, what's wrong with Grandpa?
What's wrong with Grandpa?
Grandpa will have his penicillin.
It's okay.
Oh, my God.
This is so scary when they all start killing things.
Yeah, who are they?
It was just one sheep.
Yeah.
I had a great time, guys.
It was fun.
It was so fun.
Wish you could see everybody later.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, guys.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot we were all in the Discord.
Hold on.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'll leave it.
I forgot.
We were all in the Discord, even though we were voice
proximity.
I do.
Push the talk now.
That was fun.
Am I the only one in the server?
I can tell.
Yeah, I am.
I should log off now.
Oh, yeah, like I said, Matara organized this collab.
I was like, oh, my own, it might be hard because it's like
getting all of us together in a server.
Because we're all so busy.
But I'm glad we did do it.
I was like, yeah, let me just try it out.
Just ask if everybody's free.
And then she did.
And I was just like, and I was like, yeah, I can make a
server.
Because, you know, we made the drag wound server.
So I was like, yeah, I know what to do for it.
So that's what I did for everybody.
But it had, it was really fun.
Hang out with everybody.
I hope everybody could hear each other in the game.
I wasn't sure, but I hope people could hear everything.
SoundGuy said everything was good, so I chose to believe
SoundGuy.
But I had a great time hanging out with everybody.
I just found I got a message from the rivals players, from
my rivals team.
They're like, hey, are you guys?
for a script and I'm like I'm in power world right now I was
like sorry guys I'm power worlding up right now very
dedicated I'm catching some pals I did say I'm only
available at nighttime PSC after stream I did say I I did
say that I'm just appalling it up but it was fun teaching
people how to play as well I didn't try to do hardcore mode
where I just try to fast like I had to get a mount like the
only fast track I did was just getting a mount because I
cannot be bothered I cannot be bothered to walk around it
was it's so slow when you're so used to using a mount
everything else just feels so fucking slow so I was like I
have to I have to get a fucking, I have to get a mount.
But that was the only thing I, like, did a fast grad.
No, the other stuff I was just, I was just, like, teaching
and guiding people how to play.
I didn't feel bad because, like, we were just going to set
up because I thought we were, like, streaming at 3.30.
But I didn't see that Matara wanted to start at 4.
So that was my bad because I thought we were all starting at
3.30.
uh and but then i was just like we're just setting up and
everything so i was just like all right we'll set up and
stuff uh and that's why matara joined a little late because
i didn't realize that she meant start at four playing the
game at four but we uh get together like i thought we were
starting at 3 30 so that was my bad uh but it was fun we did
we did a little prank on her though
we we we did we get to prank her though in the end Yeah, it
all worked out.
Um, but anyway, guys, uh, thank y'all for coming.
Um, I didn't, I wasn't planning on streaming today.
I'm glad I, I'm glad I did.
Um, because I was feeling super low energy.
Uh, like yesterday and today, I was super low energy.
So I had a very low battery today, a little, low social
battery.
But I'm glad I did stream because I had a lot of fun, uh,
streaming it and hanging out with everybody.
So I'm glad I did stream.
Because I wanted to, I know you guys, I want to ask your
questions about the wildcard club because I know everybody
had questions.
But I really, I need to chill now.
Because I haven't, I've only, I used to have like two rest
days when I have a really packed week.
But tomorrow it's going to be a rest day for me because I
really need to rest.
And maybe I'll do a gorilla stream.
I don't know.
But tomorrow is a rest day for me.
Because usually I do two rest days in a row just to reset
myself.
But thank you all for coming to the stream.
Coming to the collab stream today.
I had a lot of fun with all the girls today.
And as always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
Be safe for me.
Head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.